good afternoon
i'm george tagliati director of the
nevada department of public safety and
with me is
ann carpenter who is colonel
of our highway patrol on behalf of
trooper micah may's family
and the dps family we would like to
thank the kind people of our las vegas
community
our university medical center umc
so many local businesses and
organizations
our law enforcement partners who have
been terrific
our firefighters first responders our
tow truck drivers
and many more wonderful people for their
overwhelming support
and the amount of caring that they have
displayed
to the department but more importantly
to the may family
thank you very much and i'll turn it
over to the undersheriff
thank you sir
good afternoon my name is under sheriff
christopher darcy and i'm here to brief
you today on some additional details
about an officer-involved shooting an
ois that occurred on tuesday july 27
and 2021 involving members of the nevada
department of public safety
including the nevada highway patrol and
the nevada division of parole and
probation
this initial event occurred on july 27
2021
at approximately 11 19 hours and was
classified as a carjacking robbery with
a deadly weapon
the location of the ois was interstate
i-15 and spring mountain road
just south of sahara las vegas nevada
89102
you can see the scene off to my left and
if you notice the photograph that you
see on the screen you'll see that it
really spanned all the way across our
community
first i'm going to identify the involved
officers the first is trooper joseph
della bella he is 51 years old and has
been with the department of public
safety since 2004.
in this incident trooper della bello was
armed with a glock 17
nine millimeter handgun equipped with a
tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired five
rounds during this incident
the second officer is probation and
parole officer derrick
simmons he's 30 years old and has been
with the department of public safety
since 2017
in this incident officer simmons was
armed with a smith and wesson
mp 2.09 millimeter handgun equipped with
a tactical light
the investigation revealed he fired 14
rounds during the incident
the third involved officer is probation
and parole officer garrett dix
he is 28 years old and has been with the
department of public safety since
2019. in this incident officer dix was
armed with a smith and wesson mp
40 caliber handgun equipped with a
tactical light
the investigation has revealed he fired
three rounds during this incident
the fourth officer is probation and
pearl officer
luis villano villanueva he is 28 years
old and has been with the department of
public safety since 2017.
in this incident officer villanueva was
armed with a smith and wesson mp 40
caliber handgun equipped with a tactical
light
and this investigation has revealed he
fired four rounds during the incident
the suspect who will be pictured to my
left is identified as douglas claiborne
he is a 60 year old
white male adult six foot tall and
weighed approximately 177 pounds
the weapons used during this incident
were
a large kitchen knife and a
20 20 hyundai vehicle as a
used as a deadly weapon in this incident
so and as you can see from the photo of
the kitchen knife it was about a foot
long
had he not survived the applicable
charges would be
murder of a protected person robbery
with a deadly weapon
grand larceny auto and felony evading
now i'm going to go into the details of
the officer involved shooting
on tuesday july 27 2021 at approximately
11 19
hours a.m lb mpd officers responded to a
reported carjacking
at sunset boulevard and las vegas
boulevard the victim stated to
office officers that he and a co-worker
were working at a construction site
when the co-worker saw douglas claiborne
sitting in the victim's vehicle
the victim approached his vehicle and
screamed to claiborne to get out of the
car the victim attempted to open the
doors but they were locked
and then claiborne produced a large
kitchen knife and threatened the victim
the vehicle's keys were left inside of
the car
and claiborne was able to start the
vehicle he then drove away
running over the victim's foot claiborne
and the vehicle's description were then
broadcast throughout the valley
at approximately 11 50 a.m nevada
highway patrol
troopers located the stolen hyundai
traveling
northbound on interstate 15 in the area
of the speedway
exit a traffic stop was attempted by nhp
but claiborne did not stop
a pursuit was initiated and the lvmpd
air unit assisted
nhp by monitoring the pursuit from the
air
he continued northbound on i-15 and
eventually made a u-turn
and then headed southbound throughout
the pursuit claiborne exited and
re-entered the freeway
several times each time he was driving
erratically and dangerously through the
community
once back on the freeway claiborne drove
south on i-15
reaching speeds between 35 and
well over 50 miles per hour and continue
driving erratic
stop stick tire deflation devices were
deployed
numerous times yet claiborne was able to
move or
maneuver around them at approximately 12
18 p.m trooper
micah may deployed stop sticks on i-15
near the neon gateway which is by the
charleston
boulevard exit as claiborne approached
the stop sticks
he avoided the stop sticks and
intentionally intentionally drove
directly towards trooper may and struck
him with the stolen vehicle
trooper may then became lodged in the
windshield
of the vehicle as claiborne continued to
drive south on the freeway
several nevada highway patrol troopers
to include trooper della bella
accelerated up to claiborne's vehicle
the stolen vehicle
and rammed it several times the vehicle
was forcibly stopped at i-15 and spring
mountain road
just south of sahara trooper della bella
along with pnp officers
simmons dix villanueva exited their
vehicles
and officers then observed claiborne
grabbing trooper may's
gun this prompted the officers to fire
their weapons
at claiborne claiborne was struck
several times
and he was subsequently pronounced
deceased on scene by medical personnel
troopers on the scene were able to
remove trooper may from the vehicle
and immediately began life-saving
measures
the air unit landed on i-15
and transported trooper may rapidly to
umc
trauma unfortunately
on july 29th 2021 trooper may
succumb to his injuries he is survived
by his wife
and his two children i will now show you
video
from our air unit and some body worn
camera
of the ois incident
this is video of him off the freeway
driving through the
neighborhoods
carry wrong way of travel here crossing
over the uh
for the right side of travel still
northbound fifth through carry
heavy traffic down uh cheyenne he's
going off or right
on the shoulder
over here back towards the i-15
[Music]
and making another u-turn back westbound
cheyenne
looks like he's uh trying to get around
our vehicles now
uh continue once not trying to run
a way of travel 70 miles an hour
traffic's getting a little bit heavier
here he'll be up so
unless they uh smash through your cars
looks like they did
uh by the sideswipes of vehicles there
craig road
okay this is the video of the
termination of the pursuit they're going
to be trying to bench
up short medical please 15 self-centered
that's when the shots were fired
this is body cam video
that that was some body cam video from
one of the troopers that
did not fire the weapon at the time but
we felt that that body cam video
really showed the best image of the
incident
and then this last video you're going to
see will be
our air unit landing on i-15
to transport superman
okay
we believe this is the first time we've
used our air support
helicopter to actually land and rescue a
downed officer
and bring them to umc
so um this concludes my initial briefing
i'm here to answer any questions you may
have about the incident
so i'll take a few questions
anybody okay
thank you very much oh okay
from the set steve hey how you doing hey
from the start to finish when the
stolen vehicle was reported that the
pursuit began
correct to the time trooper was
airlifted
what kind of the total i could throw out
a couple of numbers
the pursuit lasted about 42 minutes
and i think it was approximately 20
minutes from the time of the initial
report till the time it was located but
the pursuit was about uh 10 minutes and
then i think it took us about
from the time the helicopter got there
and was able to land i think it was just
a couple of minutes probably three to
four minutes to to actually make the
landing and get them transported
with the channel eight uh you mentioned
that stop sticks were tried a few
a few times and they didn't we're just
able to drive around them were there
other measures
yes they were used several times uh
during as
you can see from the the map right he
went all the way up i-15
then was driving on and off the freeway
and recklessly all around and
um you know sometimes it's hard to
predict but we try to
identify those areas where it would be
safe to use them and deflate the tires
to kind of slow the pursuit down and
bring it to a safe conclusion
and that's what the officers were doing
and the troopers were doing when they
were out there
it kind of relates to those questions
with speeds of between 35 and 55 miles
an hour
uh according to radio traffic why wasn't
it why
weren't uh more aggressive tactics taken
until uh
trooper may was well i think um
and i can't speak to you know the
highway patrol policy because it was
actually
their pursuit but um i know when law
enforcement right we want to do the the
least dangerous thing we want to protect
the people on the roadway and and and
that
is paramount right the safety of the
public even the safety of the suspect
driving the car
so at that point it initially was a
pursuit within those speed limits so
a lot of times we will follow them and
eventually they'll give up or they'll
run out of gas or
they'll see that we have enough
resources unseen and then they stop
but in this case it didn't happen so
they continued to use the stop sticks to
try to
persuade him to stop and at this point
he did not stop
so about how long was it or i guess what
was the distance between
where trooper was hit and where the car
was ultimately stopped
uh well i can't tell you the exact
distance in feet
but i want to say it was about a mile
maybe a mile and a half
down between the exits
at that point he was the only one there
but earlier they had deployed him in
other spots yeah there was a total of
well six and then the seventh deployment
was the one that
um where trooper may was struck i guess
they're in a variety of places yeah i
don't have the specific places but
i will tell you this is a essentially a
72-hour briefing
we want to be transparent about the
details of the officer-involved shooting
and the death of a dedicated public
servant but this investigation isn't
over
this is just the beginning of it so in
the coming weeks and months
we'll continue to investigate follow-up
and
provide information as is asked
yes
um i can we have to make decisions in
high-stress environments
and i believe the officers i mean i
can't speak for them but i can tell you
right now the information that we have
in the preliminary investigation is
it appeared that trooper may was inside
the vehicle and
out of harm's way he was not struck with
any rounds
when the shots were fired so the
officers that are involved in it have to
make that determination
you know we always identify backdrop and
the scene where we're going to use
deadly force
so those are split-second decisions that
officers have to make in a very
challenging environment
thank you very much i appreciate you all
being here today